[Music]
at the end of the first millennium
around 1000 ad
china was definitively the most powerful
country
in the world more than a third of the
world lived within its borders
its technology was the most advanced in
existence and its economy accounted for
an astronomical
50 percent of the world's gdp the west
paled in comparison to china but
eventually
europe arose from its dark ages the
importance of china diminished
and the west came to rule the world
today that is still
largely the case but china is rising
again
in 1978 china had a gdp of only 200
billion dollars
only about 4 of the world's gdp but
nowadays that gdp
has risen to 11 trillion dollars and
accounts for 15
of all economic activity in the world
this economic renaissance of the last 40
years
is largely thanks to one industry
manufacturing
we've come to accept that china is the
world's factory but it wasn't always
this way
in the early 20th century goods were
often just produced right where they
were sold
america made american goods europe made
european goods
it wasn't until cheap worldwide shipping
became available that the production
side of a company
could be relocated to the other side of
the world but why did china win
how did this country become the
manufacturing giant it is today
in 1978 deng xiaoping took power in the
people's republic of china
he quickly visited bangkok singapore and
other flourishing asian cities and was
convinced that
in order to succeed china needed to open
itself up to the outside world
at least to an extent he gave people
control of their farms
privatized business and most importantly
allowed for an investment
in the country for the first time in
decades he opened up four special
economic zones with tax incentives and
exemption from the oversight that the
rest of the country saw on its
investments and trade activity
these four zones were essentially the
free market portions of china
but none was more successful than this
one shenzhen
in the guangdong province so i went
there to see what it was like
before its designation as a special
economic zone in 1980
shenzhen was a tiny town with about 30
inhabitants but today that's grown to
nearly 18
million people that means that its size
rivals that of new york and london
it's believed that shenzhen might have
been the single
fastest growing city in human history
every other special economic zone was an
established area before its designation
but shenzhen made sense as a spot where
china could embrace the west as it lay
just north of the border of hong kong
what was at the time of british
territory today shenzhen is the
electronics manufacturing capital of the
world
so shenzhen is a city is really known
for two things one is
its manufacturing capabilities
especially for consumer electronics
products and second is
gravitation for talents or
human resources especially on the
product development and
research and development disciplines
apple
samsung microsoft sony canon they all
manufacture products
here in shenzhen in fact 90 percent of
the world's electronics are made at
least in part
in this city everything just costs less
in china
so labor costs less too where a factory
in the united states might pay
upwards of 10 to 15 an hour a chinese
laborer would happily accept
three or four dollars an hour in
shenzhen when i was there i withdrew the
equivalent of 80
from an atm upon arrival and left four
days later with cash left over
a 30-minute taxi ride cost about seven
us dollars
a full meal at a local place was about
three dollars
but china isn't cheap entirely naturally
china has artificially depressed the
value of their currency
up until 2005 the chinese government
just said that the exchange rate was
8.271 per dollar
and that was that they then went a few
years allowing it to increase in value
within a margin
but in 2008 they pegged its value again
to make chinese exports more attractive
during the financial crisis
nowadays the government just picks an
exchange rate daily and lets the
currency fluctuate from it by up to two
percent
this just makes it so western companies
can buy more
for less china also doesn't charge taxes
on exports while the u.s doesn't charge
taxes on imports
the u.s doesn't even charge customs fees
for some products like tablet pcs
so some products can make it all the way
from their factory in china
to stores in the us completely tax-free
when i was in shenzhen i visited a
company called anchor
they make all sorts of consumer
electronics but chances are if you have
something from them it's one of their
portable batteries
i asked their ceo why so many electronic
companies are now based in shenzhen
so the advantage is that you know we're
close to the supply chain so everything
is faster
right so um instead of like you know you
do a mock-up
and um you know see it like two weeks
later
here actually you send them you know
designed to mock up and you receive
it like three days later in shenzhen
there are markets where you can buy
every part imaginable there are
factories ready to build prototypes in a
matter of days
there are engineers ready to work at a
drop of a hat
development just happens faster in
shenzhen a u.s company might use the
same factories as one based in shenzhen
but the geographical distance makes
production slower
in addition word travels fast in
shenzhen
a few years ago anker was first to
market with a technology called power iq
that allows for faster device charging
the engineers from anchor told me that a
big reason they were able to go to
market before the western companies was
because they heard about it first
thanks to the proximity to other
engineers and companies
shenzhen just produces things better and
faster but a product
isn't just a physical item police tv in
shenzhen is
being insurgent for this company is an
advantage for the supply chain that we
can
we can develop very good products with a
competitive price but for the brand it's
also a kind of a challenge
what shenzhen can't build as well is
brands certain companies like anker have
been able to to an extent thanks to
smart pr and marketing
but some other companies just don't
bother lucrative western consumers want
familiar and approachable feeling brands
but cultural differences
and geographic distance often make
chinese-based companies
just seem different all across shenzhen
i saw these boxes filled with
rentable portable chargers and as it
turns out it was an anchor product
but the chinese designed product didn't
really succeed in the western market
so actually talking about anchor box
the product is originally designed for
the western market
however actually our trial in seattle
wasn't that successful
so we realized uh first of all like
you know u.s u.s people actually
when they go to a bar they actually
really go their drinking instead of
looking at their phones
uh well if you're going walking to a bar
in china you'll you'll find
actually um like 20 tables of people
standing around looking at their phone
when the designers are thousands of
miles away from the consumer
they might not be as knowledgeable of
their wants some companies have sprung
up in shenzhen whose whole business is
to develop and produce
products without a brand they're called
white label companies
they might produce earphones for example
then sell them to a western audio
company who will attach their brand and
sell the product at a markup
despite its enormous role in increasing
the gdp of china
30-fold in the last 30 years
manufacturing is not an entirely
sustainable industry for the country
long term
the problem is that rather ironically
the economic growth that manufacturing
spurred in china
has increased labor prices to a point
where their manufacturing is less
competitive
before manufacturing came in china was a
country of poor rural
farmers but today china has a real
middle class and cities that are
expensive to live in
it used to be that workers like the ones
at anchor's factory moved to the city
for a few years when they were young to
make money for their family back home
but nowadays people are moving to cities
permanently and want to be able to set
up
solid middle class urban lives the
average cost for real estate in central
shenzhen is almost
twelve hundred dollars per square foot
that's even higher than san francisco
and new york
even when workers live outside the city
center higher wages are necessary
even just to pay for housing at the same
time manufacturing is becoming less
labor-intensive
every day as robots and automation are
becoming increasingly advanced and
inexpensive in 2015
china launched an initiative spending
hundreds of billions of dollars each
year to upgrade and automate factories
to keep prices low
but this will likely do little to keep
companies from packing up shop and
moving elsewhere
manufacturing lines that can be
automated are likely to move back to the
united states and the rest of the
western market
robots cost the same whether they're in
the united states or china
so manufacturing products in the us help
save on shipping costs and certainly is
good for pr
at the same time the labor-intensive
jobs that china prospered on in the past
decades are moving to less developed and
less expensive countries like vietnam
bangladesh and india chinese
manufacturing firms are responding to
this by opening up their own factories
all across the world everywhere from
africa to the united states itself
the model that might work for china in
the future is that of anchor
chinese-based firms that can take
advantage of their proximity to the
production lines to cut down
on development cost and time shenzhen
based startups like anker
dji and oneplus have already succeeded
in taking advantage of this proximity
but more are being established each day
if you see a hardware-based kickstarter
campaign
there's a good chance it comes from
shenzhen 10 years ago a company would be
hard pressed to succeed in shenzhen as
its own brand because historically the
retailer has acted as a barrier
in between the manufacturer and consumer
but with the rise of amazon and other
e-commerce sites
it's now possible for eastern companies
to sell directly to the western consumer
in a system that rewards for quality
over price
the time really is ripe for chinese
entrepreneurship
while silicon valley might be the
dominant area for software startups
it's hard to rival shenzhen as an
ecosystem for hardware development
and manufacturing i have to give a huge
thanks to anker for bringing me out to
shenzhen to research and film this video
it truly would not have been possible
without them and they gave me complete
creative control over the video
i've actually owned and used an anker
battery for over five years that's never
broken down
even when it's been accidentally
submerged twice and dropped countless
times but luckily they upgraded me to
one of their newest ones which i love
the main thing i want to plug for them
is their power it up contest going on
right now
10 winners will each get 2 000 in cash
and a bunch of free anchor products
to enter you make a video up to one
minute long about an unpleasant or
awkward situation caused by running out
of power
upload it to youtube then share it on
their page and the 10 highest voted ones
at the end of the contest win
the link to enter is in the description
so good luck aside from that
please be sure to check out my podcast
showmakers and subscribe to this channel
to get all my future videos right when
they come out
thanks again for watching and i'll see
you next week for another wendover
productions video